[Narrator:] In an age where average comic book movies make tons of money,
and average sequels rake in the dough,
theater nerds finally get something average to blow their wads on, too.
The Greatest Showman
From the musical geniuses behind La La Land
and Dear Evan Hansen,
comes a film full of pretty visuals
and catchy hits just begging for an overly sincere Youtube cover video.
[cacophony]
As you sing along to nine teen-friendly jams
wrapped in a story that will make you wonder:
When does the next song start?
[Charity:] The bank. They're evicting us.
[Narrator:] I'm so not here for the talky bits.
["From Now On"]
[Narrator:] Ah. That's better.
Meet P.T. Barnum:
The boy who grew from wishing he owned his own top hat
to the man who owned all the top hats,
played by noted top hat enthusiast Hugh Jackman.
M'Logan.
Follow along on P.T.'s lifelong dream
to open a weird murder museum --
[guillotine dropping]
[hearty laughter]
-- but when that doesn't pan out,
he'll roll with his backup plan:
a scam freak show,  paid for by fraud,
that he abandons his wife and kids for,
and ditches the second he has a chance to join high society.
[P.T.:] Okay, have a great show.
[Letty:] Wait -- [door slams]
[Narrator:] But after a series of show stopping musical numbers,
this social-climbing con man will be met with
[questioningly] lifelong success and happiness?
[Lettie:] Maybe you are a fraud. Maybe it was just about makin' a buck.
[Narrator:] Uh-oh. They're on to you. Quick, do a hat trick!
[ensemble laughing]
Witness this real-life Willy Wonka
but instead of selling kids candy,
he's selling kids tickets to laugh at the Oompa Loompas.
Where the tragedy of these people's exploitation is brushed aside...
[P.T.:] Well, they're laughing anyway kid, so might as well get paid.
[Narrator:] ...to spend more time with two perfect physical specimens.
Feast your eyes on a forbidden romance subplot
where Zac Efron is rich and white
but Zendaya is poor and usually a body double.
And while the circus performers have to live with being literally beaten in the streets...
[Angry Man:] You freaks!
[Narrator:] ...Efron and P.T. will get way more sympathy for having --
[gasps]
-- snobby parents.
[Mr. Carlyle:] Have you no shame?
[Mr. Hallett:] Thank you...for your honesty.
[loud slap]
[Narrator:] And [gasps] even snobbier critics.
[James Gordon Bennett:] I never liked your show.
[Narrator:] So march to the beat of your own drum with this upbeat, inspiring musical
about a really shady, cruel historical figure.
But since too much honesty doesn't sell, we've gotcha covered
with a more accurate P.T. Barnum musical.
With songs like, the "he wasn't a good guy" song:
The "made-up affair" song:
The "these two people didn't even exist" song:
And, the "rampant cruelty" song:
Laugh all you can, Barnum,
[dramatic voice:] an elephant never forgets.
Hey Screen Junkies, this month we are proud to partner with Women in Film
to raise funds and awareness for advancing the careers of women in the entertainment industry.
And on May 3rd, we're putting on the biggest Movie Fights Extravaganza in history to celebrate.
The show will be driven by your donations,
so click the box on the left or the link in the description below to find out more.
We want this to be the most epic Movie Fights event of all time,
but we can't do it without your help.
The more you donate, the more epic the show becomes.
Help us raise money for a great cause, and build a Movie Fight to remember.
Click the link now to donate and learn more.